how many titles have the Kings won I'm
going to guess uh three uh one what is
the King's record heading into tonight's
game N9 and six 10 and five who is the
King's all-time leading scorer oh that's
a good question oh Oscar Robertson uh
I'll have to go with P who is leading
the kings in total point scor this
season dear Fox dear and fox who was the
most steals for Sacramento this season
I'm going to go with dearen fox dearen
fox uh Uh Kevin
herder Kean Murray oh who is the oldest
player to start a game for the Kings
this season Harris bar ja McGee oh what
year did the Kings play their first
season in Sacramento 1978 1985 what city
is Sacramento G leue team Bas stock
stock